hello welcome to our first christmas
bone
well not christmas holiday bonus vlog
how did you cut out christmas well
because some people will celebrate
christmas
some people don't celebrate christmas
some people don't celebrate i'm trying
to be american
it's winter it's a ring ting tingling
time and we're
making cookies
hey half of me is tainting okay so we're
staying in this airbnb and i don't know
if i've showed you around yet but
there's a lot of sexual
items in here and it's fine
what we are gonna make some holiday
cookies first things first i'm a realist
these were refrigerated so we got to set
them out for like five minutes so they
warm up a little bit so we got cookie
dough we got parchment paper
i didn't bring wax paper and i forgot to
bring flour but we're gonna try our best
you don't want to use a rolling pin i
can't girlfriend well you've got it you
just take turns
look at this it's look at jess's smell
and the two people that like
perfectionism the most are
it's already melted being very
unperfectionistic
i think yeah this is hard so our
neighbor downstairs gave us flour
yay he saved the day
never got any flour that's for her
you should sprinkle it i'm eating these
cookies oh my god i
know i want to help so bad this is the
most
innocent wholesome it's soaking in my
life like i feel like there should
i feel like i um to be on brand i should
the flower for me on my sadly should be
white sugar
you know
you like go like this this is where
you're messing up you just gotta
sprinkle it she already added a whole
lot no but then she mixed it
into the dough i've been waiting for the
roll yeah all night
see these these are the only ones that
have been made so far
and those are all nicky though my
impatience
because they're first doesn't mean
they're the best yes
firstborn best born best form that that
is true
why is it all over your face why
why i can't
it looks like you did that on purpose
okay while we're waiting for the oven to
warm up
and our cookies to go in the oven i'm
gonna make the frosting
and to make that we're just using
powdered sugar and then
we're going to use a little bit of
vanilla extract in each one
like i'm talking a quarter of a teaspoon
like
very little like just a splash and then
we're doing like
a tablespoon of milk maybe a little bit
more
[ __ ] you jess i was imitating your
people
a splenish don't you know it's uh
just a splash don't you know and then
we're gonna do like different colors
and then we got different sprinkles
these are kind of cool
what's happening so tim was [ __ ]
making fun of me because i was putting
so much flour so then when she wanted
flour it went like this
i scooped it some flour
here we are
a cold december night
snow flakes fall
[Music]
these look so burnt and then these look
all undead because they're really thick
that's like us when we go on vacation
this is just
everyone else oh yeah off camera i said
i made little gingerbread men because i
wanted to make all of us
and then i said this one could be just
because the head got messed up
she's been making fun of me and telling
me my cookies are going to look bad
you should have given it pointy elbows
oh yeah the elbows aren't pointy enough
look at these elbows ew we love her
elbows we don't know why she
why she says that oh man i want point in
your elbows
my heart so many hearts they're so fat
oh that's cute they're filled with so
much love
my overweight heart that's your butt
drive fast eat us
jess is mad because she thinks we took
the pretty ones but that was after
she made fun of how bad ours were
i like it i like decorating
nerd yes a cat why are you eating the
cookies already it's the ugly one
i'm waiting for mine to cool down these
are cool
oh they're so cool that's true they're
still warm
okay everybody has to submit one cookie
that's like their best cookie
okay and then everyone the viewers can
be like try to guess who did what one
and who won oh but they're seeing us
decorate i know i'm gonna i'm gonna turn
this off
looks just like her i need to make
voodoo cookies of all of you
god are you gonna eat them yeah all
y'all's talking about your dry spells
three months for this one a few weeks
for that one
look at nikki's cute little cookie
cute little sneaky cookie thanks
i tried to make a tanner version for you
know the rest of us this is just
what did you add red color
it's flesh though
all right are we done yeah
okay here are the finished products
and we're submitting one cookie each so
i think
this cookie is from someone
oh so we're not going to say in this
yeah you're going to try to get they're
going to even vote
in the comments but okay so remember you
have to guess who
who's cooking somebody make a top
comment so that with like four top
comments
or something what before someone make
the four
top comments which cookie they like the
most someone make a top comment for a
[ __ ] yellow cat and then the number
of likes that gets that's how they win
oh and then if you like this other one
that one gets the number of likes that's
how you think
this comment section is that organized
say who you think
did each cookie and who would you
like the best yeah i mean earlier this
b-roll was making the cookie
i know don't look at that here's another
one that somebody made
okay this one is somebody's it's an
american flag one
it's an american flag snowflake who is
proud to be an american
and um
and and this one is somebody's
whose might that be they're waving an
american flag
it's mitch mcconnell oh my god this
one's somebody's
those are the four i know the only one
doesn't count this one doesn't count
this one's apolitical
it includes everyone yeah all right guys
that's that hope you enjoyed our our
cookie
box what's your name though did you see
all the big mood girls
wow they look so accurate which one's
mean nickel accuracy
which one's sweet doesn't sound like a
faint sound
which one's me nikki
why mickey what well it it looks like
you you have pretty eyelashes
eyelashes and you got pretty lips
this one's me uh i ran out of black so i
couldn't wear a black shirt like
i try to make everyone's outfits the
outfits that they're wearing
i like mine how you did my eyes
brown roots that's gina going like this
guys
what's going on with her mouth she's
going like this
it's so dumb
see and then that one's jess she's got a
really blank look on her face
there's the eyes you didn't show my
mister mister this is mr and mrs this is
mrs
screaming i think she married up
hold your cookie up the accuracy why is
it what at the bottom
i'm still acting it's accurate the
accuracy
oh wow which one's the cookie you'll
never guess
the accuracy that's smaller
c c c c wait
[Laughter]
it's funny because the like the color
shifted down
i'm dripping oh gina take care of
yourself
take care of yourself dude you're
bleeding actually it's that time
these are my voodoo cookies yeah these
are vegan cookies
nicky what do i look like my makeup's
all red
you've been crying you're a water sign
she's like i haven't had dick in three
months i haven't
look at the tears i'm crying at the club
hello it's night two here at the big
mood and we
are going to celebrate the new moon by
welcoming in new
intentions into our lives and harnessing
[Laughter]
we are witches i normally would bring a
bigger crystal but i forgot it came out
are you
do you have crystal embarrassment i am
embarrassed for this crystal
so this is not a powerful crystal oh
it's not the size we're gonna
invite we're gonna imbue it with the
greater good of all uh
do you think it can handle it yes oh
okay now it's imbued
okay what does that mean it means i put
all the you know good intentions on it
so it's it's crazy i'll leave my
intentions out of it
face tonight that's great that's the
last of our ones these intentions last
for six months though so
you want to be wasted for the next six
months
accurate oh but first tiff over here
she brought her tarot card this is her
first time ever using tarot cards and
last night
she was just doing a [ __ ] around like
we were all like a fake read
another thing yeah and she's like okay
this one's for jess and she would do a
card reading and it would be super
accurate
yeah all she did for gina everyone's was
really accurate
i have a gift that i just haven't tapped
into and then i always look towards
nikki because i'm like nikki i feel like
the universe is calling for me can you
please
guide me you know what it is she's cause
she's mexican you know those brew houses
yeah yeah and uh uh my dad
used to practice some [ __ ] that i don't
know what he would practice he had a
like a little what is it trying to do a
shrine
no he hasn't said a practice sanseria
he had a crystal ball no but yeah my dad
had a shrine
and he would worship the the saint of
death so there would be
your dad was a devil worshiper i don't
know
but a lot of people tell me they're like
the saint of death is
like like cartel [ __ ] the saint of death
is the fallen angel
what's his name no he had a statue
that was like a skeleton statue statue
statue we've had a
little bit of wine this one one one
glass
one
so my dad would do that and he would
also leave out a like a little copa what
is it
a glass a cup yes yeah so he would leave
it
like a thing of tequila and he would
always tell me when i was little like
see look the spirits
are drinking from it because alcohol
would evaporate and they would go down
but he would tell me like see me see the
spirits are looking out for us and i'm
like
okay um we just came about evacuation
evaporation in third grade
i'm like all right dad sure whatever but
anyway
i'm saying all of this because i'm like
listen it's in my blood somehow
and i feel drawn to this [ __ ] and last
night when i was just playing around
it was pretty [ __ ] accurate i don't
know
so we're gonna see what happens tonight
when we do the ship
but first we have to cleanse the cards
and the house because we just told
murder stories and also i touched
you touched my tips cards and i was
shuffling them and apparently nikki said
no one should touch a a person's
own deck oh my god did you touch your
back i touched her dog
oh my my god after that so we're going
to
first use sage and this is going to
cleanse everything out so we're going to
clear out
all the bad energy hopefully the fire
alarm doesn't go off because sometimes
it goes off in my house it's
super embarra that
[Laughter]
this is not twerking okay i was just
chosen
wait you gotta you gotta flex what are
you doing my flexing goes down
oh see no mickey don't don't bend your
pelvis like your pelvis stays straight i
can't do that
oh [ __ ] yeah what are you doing you
can't do that you flex your butt
i can't do it either it flex up it only
flexes down you know
i was just standing here like this dude
okay do it do it do it i am see yours
goes how mine goes it like goes
down yeah i don't [ __ ] wait flexing
your pelvis
okay okay just the butt the [ __ ] stays
still
how cute pretty kitty ooh that was
creepy
this is sage it's a cleansing okay so
while we're
while we're staging we're gonna go to
every corner and just be like do you
need the feather
yeah you can like you can do this but i
just i don't really do that that much
i'll do it i want the whole okay
only looking like i hope we don't set
off the fire alarm i'm seriously
there's a lot of smoke over here all
right
the light lives it smells like weed a
little bit
oh wait you got to cleanse the [ __ ] out
of those because i touched it all in the
crevices
yeah just touched them you got it you
gotta really cleanse it really like
like really really nails in there and
shampoo it yeah keep
keep uh keep the fire alarm from going
off please
oh my god what the [ __ ] is an abalone
yeah it's a it's a mullet the next thing
i'm gonna light is this palo santo
and i usually only like this for new
moons because it brings like a
new energy so the sage clears out all
the bad
and this enters all the good so this is
inviting where do you buy energy which
is our us
yes which is our us somewhere in west
hollywood this is actually
um this was a stocking stuffer for me
but usually i'm at a crystal shop
um there's thank you for your service
mrs
darling just trying not to get goddamn
fine
i know gina before she starts is there
anything in particular
that you would like guidance on uh
future choices
letting things go money i want more
money
family men and money reversed two of
swords
you are in a stalemate unable to decide
which direction to take
release your grip on having to find the
right solution
look at both sides and consider
alternatives not very helpful
uh upright ace of wands you are highly
motivated
energized and filled with new ideas that
inspire growth a world of possibility is
opening up
follow your passion it's pretty generic
but very generic
yeah eight of cups upright
i think because it was generic questions
asked too like give me the
general it is time to walk away from a
disappointing situation
or a relationship you wanted it to work
it happened the only option is to move
on with your life
got it okay nicky limo green
i swear to god if i get a death card or
a tower card i'm leaving
i always get a death card or a tower
card oh my god
which is all about like you know
reinvention
and like basically burning from ashes
and coming up
from the actual phoenix getting down
through the ashes
let me get out of these ashes damn no
more phoenixes
an upright high priestess oh she's cool
and uh reversed the emperor
okay upright king of cups i'm looking at
my tiny
recess i'm a priest yeah i know i know
what i'm saying
i know what i'm saying where is it i
don't know what i'm saying oh here she
is okay upright high priestess
you are in tune with your intuition and
your higher self
the answers you seek lie within access
your inner wisdom and divine feminine
energy
the whap has the power you got a
reversed
emperor be mindful of your relationship
with power and authority allow this
energy to flow through you not against
you
i do hate authority last night was like
way more on point yeah that sounds
pretty great i know
last night the accuracies you could have
been there maybe it's because i touched
those cards maybe i'm the one with the
power
will we cleanse them from scratch oh
yeah because you touched them yesterday
you have to touch them again
[Music]
tips like them before i think no i
touched them i touched them before you
did the readings
yeah okay king of cups upright
you are in control of your emotions and
have the maturity to feel your feelings
wrong i wasn't just crying in the
kitchen this afternoon
over cornmeal yeah but you did have a
pretty
good hold i feel like in in the previous
sentences would have
just melted i did do melts in the floor
a lot
yeah okay i have jessica caldwell
called well caldwell no one
they've known me for [ __ ] like five
or six years and i still can't say
yes i get it right i always get it right
i'm such a dog
ooh jumping cards what does happen
those are like extra insights sometimes
it's okay what does that mean when it
jumps
wait what do you mean what i didn't see
it it's like the deck oh like as she's
trying to put them together
two cards jumped out
oh we gotta ignore that so i don't know
next time yes let's see jess what do the
cards say for you why don't she break
her dry spell
i like okay so i'm gonna set mine very
specifically in my head
because i can't say too much in the
public we're allowed to do that you guys
didn't tell me that
oh you didn't ask but you guys you guys
know what i'm saying
is is a person that i'm considering
worth considering uh yes yes
um should i continue taking my exams
yes those are my two
all right here we go you got an upright
three of cups
a reversed seven of wands
and a reversed two of what pentacles
pentacles okay three of cups
celebrate your successes with your
closest friends and family i do
collaborate with others on a creative
project and inspire
one another to reach new heights we
continue to do that reverse
seven of wands external pressure is
weighing you down
leaving exams leaving you doubting
yourself and whether everything is worth
it don't let your doubts
get to you so keep taking this own your
position and don't censor yourself to
keep others happy
maybe that's about online persona don't
censor myself
yeah just to keep others more of myself
yeah two of pentacles
reversed your schedule is overloaded and
you are dropping the ball
get yourself organized and don't be
afraid to ask for help you're not
expected to do everything on your own
i was so focused on the politics when
the election happened and stuff that i
had to actually push my exam back
you did i pushed my exams that was true
yeah so it's like get your [ __ ] together
on the exam it's like not even don't be
afraid it's not even answering the guy
questions so i think the universe is
like
it is my turn to read my own cards and
honestly i'm not even super attached to
this reading because
seeing how all your love came out i'm
like it was
it's because we got spoiled last night
was so laggy
it was so perfect i just gotta throw it
away i think i'm trying too hard
yeah you gotta throw it away yeah [ __ ]
this card
upside down the high priestess oh uh
upright judgment upright nine of
pentacles
says let go of ego and fear and learn to
trust your intuition go within and
listen to your inner voice
i'm trying uh upright judgment this is
your time to rise up
you are experiencing a huge spiritual
awakening and realizing that you are
destined for so much
more this is your cosmic up leveling be
ready to tune
into a higher frequency
okay nine of pentacles you have created
abundance
now enjoy the fruits of your labor don't
be afraid to splurge on something
special for yourself
use your wealth to create financial
independence
in the long term that doesn't sound like
a baby
that's awesome none of this sounds like
you're just going to be a rich lady
it sounds like i'm going to be a rich
witch i think you need to be a witch and
you need a charge that's dope
do you think the baby's around like the
ego fear
maybe like you're winning if you get one
and like you're losing you know i don't
get one so you're not
bringing the right energy into for the
implantation because you're just like
oh this is a win or lose situation i
have to make it it definitely feels that
way about getting pregnant with the
outside pressures yeah it's just like
too it's too much outside pressure and
it's all
focused on me when i'm like there's two
people in this equation
and i just feel like why is that like
that yeah i think it's such an
outdated thing that like the woman's
responsible for
not being barren yeah it's it's a lot of
pressures i like my reading yeah
you got money okay do over rich witch
yeah i'm down
gina i can think about my questions now
yeah yeah think specifically in your
head and think about it while she's
shuffling like think about it a lot oh
hold on
all right none of y'all want to jump
okay that's fine i'm the only special
one with the jumping
i was like white and then just like
i was like
get your yeah out of the way i had no
idea gina
you got what should be the same person
reversed ace of
wands okay reversed the sun
oh cool upright queen of the kitty
yeah you can feel an idea emerging but
you are uncertain
what form it will take or how you will
manifest it in the world
you may keep your idea private for now
until
you have more confidence in taking it
forward there we go
it's you can have your private for now
you keep it private
until you have more confidence in taking
it forward okay
you've got a little side business if
you're not thomas you want to open up a
brothel
[Laughter]
yeah absolutely premium price i have
like yeah but watch
jess get so many clients and and she's
like no you're toxic
no no i'm not doing that you're not high
value
no get out of here no yeah
everybody walk through the door i'm like
no nope not you
no we like they like in degradation the
moment she does it they're like oh thank
you
that's my money don't [ __ ] touch me
okay
give me money all right gina reversed
son you may feel depleted or exhausted
retreat from the outer world to
re-energize and recharge
you do not have to be on she's been
doing that
that's all she does that's yourself card
i got you you got this card last night
i'm so
[ __ ] exhausted yeah
[Laughter]
okay queen of wands uprights always the
social butterfly
you lead a busy life making connections
with others and putting yourself out
there as you pursue your creative vision
you are confident courageous and
determined unafraid to speak up and be
heard
did any of that have to do with the
specific question you asked
uh no well work one yes the other one's
no not really yeah i think the last
reading
the middle this one for sure said a few
things son yeah
i need a [ __ ] vacation here now that
you know your readings
we're gonna set our intentions for the
next six months why are you drunk
now camera just focus on this camera's
drug test
i don't know if it's the camera maybe
it's the sun my eyes are blurry
like why am i not in focus
[Music]
15 minutes holy [ __ ] anything for that
level oh my god
[Music]
anyway how's everyone feel feel cleansed
i feel planned yay i mean i've never
done this before so like throughout the
thing i was just thinking like doing
this right like is this right
so i tried really hard yeah you
literally just closed your eyes and like
listen to what he's saying and that's it
yeah yeah i'm cycling
intentions for myself and then when i
ran out i was like giving some
intentions for gina
and tim oh that's sweet what a
thoughtful [ __ ]
i seriously feel like i fell asleep like
five times and like my head just kept
like don't give me a wig
breathe in the good [ __ ] exhale the
[ __ ] that's all kept thinking
oh that's awesome okay listen you are
a loving [ __ ] you're happy
you got so much to be grateful for like
because i feel like the past
always weighs me down heavily like i'm
one of those people
same and i'm just like listen the past
doesn't pass it can't hold you
down anymore and i just kept telling
myself don't let them take your power
cleansed from the past this was nice i
felt refreshed
yeah i felt like so in our meditation
the guy
like immediately was like let all this
[ __ ] go and i felt like after
he said that like it just felt like you
i let it go and then i just went blank
inside i've never been so quiet for so
long
[Laughter]
true terrifying unless you're on your
phone looking through [ __ ] yeah
it was nice it was a nice feeling good
yay i
feel cleansed i love the scents too yeah
yeah
the other stuff like i just feel it like
cleansing my
energy like my soul i'm just like clean
it's like my soul took a shower
all right bye everybody i hope you like
that give us a thumbs up we'll see you
later bye
[Music]